[Music]
good to see you it's good to see you I'm
super excited to reprise our guru corner
sessions it is joy and you know in
watching them I noticed that you not
only have a strong sense of where the
conversation should go but you your team
also has a strong sense of how to edit
and the editing is remarkably accurate I
mean it's just like Cheech yeah they're
doing really jobs right here and and
Margo thumbs up how about doing well you
go back and watch them I never go back
and listen or watch you know I go back
and watch just to see how you know how
it all pieced together but yeah you're
right it's hard to go back and when
you're always going forward it's it's
hard to go back and and inspect things
that have have been yeah now I'm just
moving forward but I went back and
looked at it just for the just for the
curiosity of how it was all being you
know assembled remarkable well the
people that listened to this on audio
only are always fascinated by the
jangling of your bracelets it's not
until you see on video that you actually
understand what's going on right well we
have a great subject that we're gonna
dive into today but before we do that I
wanna I want to catch up with you
because you you've been on some
interesting travels lately yeah which of
the Middle East we went to the Middle
East who spent a week in Abu Dhabi on
the on the coast there of the UAE and
taught to a group of people that are you
know changemakers in the world that was
part of the Tony Robbins thing correct
like his behind the velvet rope like
heavy-hitting clients right his his
group called the Platinum partners
uh-huh and yeah it's it's a solid group
of people that not only have succeeded
on you know in three dimensions and in
four dimensions but that are really
seeking to succeed in their in their
spiritual life too
they're in there compassionate life in
their love life in their in the world
that's beyond that you know that world
of beyond the scene mm-hmm
yeah so what does that look like I mean
what is the practical sort of schedule
like how do you want to start with yoga
at either 6:30 or 7:00 in the morning
and we go through yoga before breakfast
then we'll all go to breakfast you knows
about just under 300 people hmm and Tony
do the yoga Tony does his yoga yeah and
then go to breakfast and then come
together for a day of working with Tony
and a variety of other people this year
everybody was brought into Abu Dhabi
some years there's been some sky pins
you know with some teachers like Ram
Dass from from Maui but this year the
people that were to teach and to present
all flew in and it was a powerful
powerful gather who were some of the
other teachers a dock master Co and he's
you know a lot of work with the energy
field
he's a chi gong master and other and
then also a professor of Religious
Studies at at Boston College at BC and
his was just really bringing you know
the five major religions into a focus
and letting everybody see the
similarities and differences and
historically where that all took place
so that's another topic he had an
incredible medical doctor who lives both
in Italy and in and in Israel and a
profound energy worker
that and then Byron Katie oh wow and she
she presented so it was beautiful it was
a breakthroughs with some of these
people with the attendees oh yeah yeah I
mean that the attendees have
breakthroughs in morning yoga and Tony
in Tony's presentations and in others
yeah I mean breakthroughs right and left
you know right well speaking of
breakthroughs the subject that we kind
of discussed diving into today I'm very
excited about I think it's an important
one I think it's relevant to a lot of
people if not everybody on some level
which is this idea of how to be true to
oneself in a world that values
conformity I personally have quite a bit
of experience with those and I think we
could probably talk about this for many
hours yeah we could because Confucius
had a had a favorite saying and that is
that the tallest tree in the forest
catches the most wind every other tree
just thinks it's called and so when
we're living in a world of
psycho-emotional wind in the form of
judgment in the form of inspection and
observation you know people like to hide
down in the forest because it allows
them to be less of that outstanding self
and they don't catch as much attention
wind as Confucius said well not only do
they want to avoid that wind there's a
lot of external pressure whether it be
familial or professional to to to hide
in that way to conform you know what I
mean like there's not a lot of we I feel
like we speak out of two sides of our
mouths on the one hand we're saying be
different you know like the Apple
advertising campaign but in truth I
think we're just giving lip service to
that because most of the energy goes
into trying to make sure that we conform
to a certain sort of preordained set of
behaviors rules professions
and anytime anybody steps just a little
bit outside of that there's a lot of
energy that goes into saying not so fast
get in mind yeah there's a couple of
pieces of that too and there's there's
the the the familial piece that you
spoke up and that you know goes back
through the generations what did the
family find convenient comfortable which
is conforming because if you are too
different then you will be judged you
will be analyzed you will be
investigated inspected all of those
things which feel uncomfortable but the
other piece of that is also that there's
a thing called a fraud factor in
evolution and you know anthropologists
have studied this for a long time and it
takes place in all of the species and
the fraud factor is that if you if you
change too much too quickly it's
considered a mutation and that gets
struck down by this psycho emotional
fraud factor you feel you feel like you
feel like a fraud you feel like a fake
and so that evolutionary thing is kept
the species from accelerating too
quickly because you know in some species
if the if the offspring were too
different than the parenting generation
the parents wouldn't recognize them and
therefore wouldn't take care of them
right would reject the offspring would
reject it's like a rejection of an organ
inside your body I mean at all in
microcosm and macrocosm is the same
event but you can also see that this
fraud the sense of feeling like one is a
fraud can also blossom in somebody is
trying to can do a best to conform even
though deep down in their unconscious
mind they know they're living the wrong
life for themselves yeah I'm thinking so
are you a fraud to the culture or
society in which you live or are what
you're saying is are you a fraud to
yourself
exactly yay
yeah I like that because and that's
that's those you know quote crises
moments that take place in our lives
when as you were saying earlier when we
were just talking before going on Mike
that mmm you know you just couldn't do
it anymore right
you couldn't reconcile the vast
difference between what you were
passionate about and what you were doing
every day yeah I mean that's why this
subject matter is so personal for me
because I was somebody who tried very
hard to conform I did everything that I
could to be that person I was expected
to be you or that i intuited I was meant
to be you and I came to the same place
from two opposite directions keep going
right yeah so no I was the good boy who
was studying hard to get the good grades
to get into the good college and get
into the grad school but my my vision
was very focused on just what was in
front of me to do next on this Habitrail
of success and progression in the
context of our Western developed world
capitalistic society to prioritizes
security and upward mobility and
respectability above everything else and
I did my best to play this game and I
feel like I was successful in playing
that game and it took some serious
crises in my life for me to step outside
of that and reckon with it you know I
feel like I have if I have a talent it's
the ability to suffer and to endure to
have somebody else do that as an athlete
but Michael Evans but it's also I could
do that emotionally too so even though
early on I realized like hey this lawyer
thing or this law school thing probably
isn't for me I could will myself through
it yeah even though I knew I was wearing
the wrong pair of shoes and wearing the
wrong pair of glasses and I really had
to get my knees capped in order to make
some changes it took that for me so I
think kind of extrapolating out
this is something this is this is
something that I think people experience
on a spectrum right to it to a matter of
degrees on the very far end there are
people who are fully expressed in their
own unique blueprint somebody like
yourself on the very other end there are
people who are extremely repressed to
feel like they're you know they're
living somebody else's life or or who
are so disconnected from themselves that
they have no conscious awareness of that
which is an important thing to put on
there a numbness in order to survive in
order to continue yes right survive and
then you know just to finish this
thought yay in the middle is is probably
the more typical person who's kind of
going about their day-to-day their job
isn't that great but it's not so
terrible that they're gonna do anything
about it they wish they had made this
left turn or that right turn along the
way but they didn't and everything's
okay they got a roof over the head they
can pay their bills just barely and hey
you know maybe in the next life and
there's a settling that occurs with that
and I think that's the real tragedy and
I where I'd like to kind of focus this
discussion so the person in the middle
think of it as a middle child right that
doesn't go to either extreme doesn't get
completely wiped out by the conforming
but also doesn't test themselves to see
how far they can go you used a word will
you said you will your way through it
it's an interesting mechanism will and
willingness and willpower it's an effort
that comes from the chest it's an effort
that comes from the heart center its
willingness and the willful
implementation of your desires does not
come from a thought process it comes
from animo ting process that you
actually have that will that's why if
people if to athletes are the same and
one exceeds the other one they say they
put their heart into it right because on
paper they were they were matched up
very well
those that live in the center you know
that's one of the most agonizing places
to be I mean I was in the center because
of the Vietnam War I was trying to stay
inside of something called college which
you know my passion was music and it was
not until I had a health crisis and went
through a process that took me out of
school that I had to go through the
ordeal of proving to the draft that they
had no want or desire for me in any way
shape or form and then I was free but
there are often those extenuating
circumstances that people have built up
like you said meeting their mortgage
their car payments barely or even
successfully those extenuating
circumstances that life builds up you
need a shelter you need a place to live
you need transportation you need a car
you need food you need clothing you need
all of these things which cost and then
you have to build up that cost the the
agrarian time we were quite unique but
over the last three or four hundred
years and the industrial times is when
we become very conforming think about
when you were oh you you were talking
about your high school year prep school
you said suit and tie or coat and tie
you know that tie comes from the slave
days I mean I'm talking way back in the
Roman slaves you had this steel collar
iron collar around your neck and you had
this chain that went down to your belt
which was a piece of rope and that that
chain that went down to your belt would
be hooked to that rope during the day
and then at night that chain would be
attached to the rod that held everyone
in bed and that's why they called it a
tie because it tied you to the job you
think about all how did that work into
the modern day version of the time
it's kind of poetically beautiful isn't
it isn't it I mean the bottom line is is
that it morphed into there was dress
codes to show your allegiance to show
your dedication and your devotion not
even that to the company I mean it's not
so much now there's a big movement away
from ties but this is what God everybody
into that it was your parents generation
it was my parents generation even though
I think I'm more like your I'm more in
age your parents I have me I feel like
your child you know what I'm saying I do
not I do not feel anything near what I
am in age but that tie was a was part of
the dress code mm-hmm it's interesting I
mean in thinking about agrarian times I
would imagine the opportunities for
individualistic expression were probably
pretty limited like if you grew up in a
farming family you were gonna be a
farmer and there weren't a lot of
options now we have you know an
unlimited number of options and
opportunities for young people just the
awareness of what's possible is now at
everybody's fingertips because of the
computing age that we live in and yet at
the same time there is this pressure to
adhere to a certain set of standards in
terms of what's acceptable to do and
pursue and what isn't you know I agree
and the agrarian times before the
Industrial Times just imagine everyone
was an entrepreneur everyone worked for
themselves for the most part right you
had your crops you planted them in your
own way you you planted them in relation
to the moon you were very much attuned
to some of those things which people
have completely lost sight of now but
your clothes you know whether you are a
bandana or you are a hat or what kind of
hat was it straw was it leather was it
cloth you know everybody was very
individualized there was a there was yes
you were a farmer and you were raised by
farmers and you were gonna give birth to
farmers but what we what are you gonna
raise and how are you
do it and and all of those other things
which in the world of today's industrial
condition we may feel like we have a lot
of options but we boil ourselves down to
trying to be like so that we won't stand
out as we were saying that middle that
middle group that's neither at neither
extreme they are on a they are on a
progression towards individuality in
most instances and that's why in some
cases that's where the greatest agony is
because as they are still trying to fit
in like in your world what you are
describing as they're still trying to
fit in they know full well that there's
no way that they're passionate about
doing so
they've developed enough awareness that
they've slid from being completely numb
to being aware enough to feel the
discomfort yeah that's the most painful
that is the be and it's the pain of
birth you know being born into yourself
the bottom line of what do they call it
midlife crisis that doesn't really
happen at the middle of life it can
happen at any point but all of a sudden
in that crisis the person just starts
blaming their surroundings for having
held them into this place that they
don't want to be in the crisis is to use
anger or whatever they can do to break
out of to have a breakthrough yeah or
victimhood good yeah and stay in it
through victimhood so in order to even
get to that middle place though you have
to develop that base level of
self-awareness to kind of understand
what makes you tick what's uniquely you
what is it that you would like to more
fully Express who is the person you
would imagine yourself to be in a
best-case scenario but just to get to
that point requires a level of heart
connection I would imagine just to
initiate that process out of the haze
you know the the the waking day dream of
just existence
following the commands of society you
know people have many different ways
children breaking out of this will
oftentimes have a pet that gets them out
a dog or a cat or something in which
they could truly be themselves I was
interested in your story because when
you were when you went into prep school
you said that swimming is what pulled
you out because all of these things had
caused sports that cause us to breathe
particularly things like running and
swimming and bicycling that caused us to
breathe deeply and consistently that'll
get us out because that is a heart
centered event right the two lungs that
surround the heart so go into a little
bit of that what happened to him and
swimming yeah I very much felt out of
place in this school and was confused
about who I was and what I wanted to be
I knew that this academic institution
was not an ideal situation for me I
didn't fit in I was a sensitive kid in a
very kind of alpha male lacrosse and
football focused situation helmets and
face masks there was a lot of that you
know all-boys school right I got an
amazing education you know so I don't
it's not like you know it was terrible
but it just wasn't it didn't fit who I
was and I found swimming and I
gravitated towards that and there was
something about that endeavor that fit
me like a glove and a lot of it I think
in retrospect looking back on that
experience I think I was in a lot of low
level emotional pain that was confusing
for me and there was something about the
water then made me feel grounded when my
head was underwater all the noise went
away and it was very simple
it's just put in effort move forward and
there's a binary kind of linear equation
with these workouts where the harder I
work the better I got it made sense plus
you're floating and at home
you were buoyant and floating which is
an antigravity ya what's interesting
this is a little bit of a tangential
aside but I think it's relevant
Julie Julie said she's been saying to me
she has this weird theory that I fall
somewhere on the autism spectrum I was
gonna take real issue I'm like really
you think she's like no you're very
you're much more sensitive than you
think I would take that as a comment so
she's like you're a lot more sensitive
than then you think you are so she's
always trying to find ways to help me
and she came across this thing called a
gravity blanket have you heard of it
yeah some friends of mine put it on the
market futurism oh really
yeah so she's like you should try this
gravity blanket as I my sense what I
understand this could be wrong was that
this blanket which has weights in it
yeah basically it's very heavy yeah it's
like those it's like when you go to a
dentist and you're having an x-ray you
know that it's like a big boom she
apparent from what I understand these
were developed for autistic children hmm
they were and when you put them on top
of them they just they calm down they
feel grounded they feel like they can
relax she's like I think you would
really like this and and we got one I
got one like four days ago I struggle
with sleep it's always difficult for me
to fall asleep unless I'm training super
hard which is why I sleep in a tent and
that's a whole other story and I got to
tell you I have had the best last seven
nights of sleep yep since I was a little
kid like being she's like how would that
feel to be like oh that actually would
feel really good yeah so we got it and I
gotta tell you being under that thing I
feel fantastic and I'm having the most
restful sleep in recent memories well
I'll help put you together with the
company about this so this is like a
revelation and I was talking to a friend
of mine who's a therapist and an
addiction medicine specialist I said hey
do you know about these gravity blankets
he's like dude I've been on this for you
a long time he has one he's all about it
I was like I wish I discovered this
years ago he's like yeah and I'm like
what is it about this that is making it
work so well that's agreeing with me so
much isn't the embrace he said that a
lot of addicts and alcoholics and
recovery respond very well to it because
there's something about their background
that was chaotic or emotionally
destabilizing where they never felt like
they could let their guard down and just
relax this is a 20 for those of you
listening this is a 20 pound blanket
just that literally hugs every portion
of your body against the mattress
exactly and what it's doing is it's
giving you the womb sensation it's the
reason why the native indigenous people
would create that Papoose right it's in
biblical times it's what they called
swaddling clothes where they would wrap
the small child so that it would be you
know feel more secured but it's just
taking you back to that mother point in
that womb in which everything was taken
care of it's a very secure sensation
it's an embrace yeah I feel I can relax
yeah and let my guard down and so this
friend of mine was saying yes when you
put the blanket on it allows your
sympathetic nervous it sends signals to
your sympathetic nervous system like
it's okay it's safe yeah it ignores you
into the parasympathetic and it's been
amazing and it's made me think about
reflect on other decisions that I've
made to kind of create these womb like
environments I know when I would need to
be a spokesman what I would say yeah I
know this sounds like an ad for this
thing it's not you know but but I I
recall when I was in high school and I
had to study for an exam I would pull
all the blinds down and turn all the
lights off in my bedroom and shut the
door and just have a desk lamp and now I
have this container space my container
office and when we were constructing it
Julie's like don't you want Windows we
can put a big window in it I was like no
I don't want any windows I want no
windows I want to be able to just seal
it and be in my womb
she's like you gotta have some windows
so we put these little windows on it and
now I put like a blanket over the
windows because I don't want that I want
to feel like I am in the womb and that
so I think these are very similar
impulses that I have to create an
environment that that is like being
swaddled as a baby my morning practice
is done the portions of it that are just
deep deep meditation are done in a very
large walk-in closet in the center of
our home that has no wall to the outside
right and when I shut the door on that
walk-in closet its pitch black it's it's
like the quad see in my previous days of
in deep Mexico but the bottom line is is
that those those cave-like components
are very much where we can go back to
our seed right in in sanskrit it's
called beach when you can go back to
that beach in your existence that seed
in your existence where every branch of
your life is still possible and then you
can sort of recapitulate recalculate
your life and form new challenges and
form new efforts and form new
possibilities and form new opportunities
you were talking about how in swimming
when you were a child the water made a
lot of sense i was i started music at
the age of 5 but performing music in
front of people was really challenging
for me because you know i just wanted to
go out there and you know out into the
music and do it but a performance you
had to be he had to be right in each
moment right so that was that was so
limiting so what I did in my middle
school and high school days as I got
into acting where you were literally
applauded for being off the map and
that's what allowed me to come back into
my music and be able to be that same act
on any stage which then allowed me to
come back into my life and basically say
to heck with conformity to the enth
degree and be able to do that so you
used water and I use just I used a
volcano so you use the element of water
and I use the element of fire yeah well
I think you're that's beautiful I think
your your trajectory towards
nonconformity I don't like that that's a
negative to individual individual
individualized expression was a was a
little less circuitous took me a little
bit longer but you're somebody who cuts
a very unique you know image right like
when you walk down the street like you
don't look like everyone else yeah and I
give you a hard time
no no not at all like when you're
traveling or anything like that no you
went to the Middle East when you're in
airports yeah no it's a it's like I am
so at ease with Who I am that I don't
know that I'm different than you uh-huh
and the fact that you're if I don't know
to the nth degree that I'm different
than other people then there's a
sensation of connection and I think
people feel it I think people feel it
people feel all he's really weird but
he's really connected he's kind of
harmless you know he's like we don't
need to hassle him you know and so ya
know it's rare it's rare that my wife
and I actually have any kind of
imposition pushed upon us because of the
way we are I mean I've heard people say
that when when I when they arrived and I
arrived at a particular setting like for
example the ones that we just did in Abu
Dhabi you know they say oh my god what
have we gotten ourselves into here and
then after after the first encounter
they go oh this is cool right because
you have all these like high-powered
business people they're like what's this
guy gonna tell me yeah and all of a
sudden they realize that I'm talking to
them like their own psycho-emotional
consciousness
talks to them when it's friendly the
idea that the middle the middle patch of
that conformity non-conforming of the
individualization and the non
individualized that middle path being
the one of agony you know those are
oftentimes the ones that are most driven
and and tend to succeed also because the
agony is something that they're running
from and so maybe it's if I do more of
this
I'll have it maybe if I achieve more of
this I'll be I'll get away from it and
so it's a stimulant so it's not just a
it's not a negative in total it's it's
it's got a lot of positives as well that
agony and will grow through pain
obviously you practice that on a day
week month basis right yeah but I mean
this journey to - you know
self-actualization can be forged through
pain it doesn't have to no it doesn't
and I feel like somebody who is in their
full expression is an individual we
generally celebrate like once somebody's
you know at the fruition of that
experience and they're fully expressed
and they're in their creative flow or
they're doing whatever they're doing and
they are who they are even if they're
completely off the map from that
conformist idea of what a person is
supposed to look like we do as a culture
tend to celebrate those people as
inspirational or aspirational the
challenge or the difficulty comes in the
early phases of that journey for that
person when they're just starting to
step outside the boundaries a little bit
right they haven't fully developed yet
to the place where we can celebrate all
their unique glory
mm-hm it's those early phases where it's
easy to swat somebody down and say not
so fast come on get back in line
you know this is these are the people
that in many instances that are
listening to your podcast that are
listening to this broadcast not not all
but a good portion and the bottom line
for those people is that they should
understand what you just said if you're
going to
step out you're gonna have to expect the
pushback right in a material space for
every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction and they should
actually gauge their progression by the
amount of pushback right they're
receiving
they could use that but it takes courage
and the fortitude and and it takes a
real sense like it's very that's a very
fragile state for these people that's
why it's so easily quashed because
you'll second-guess that impulse that's
driving you to do something a little bit
different because everybody around you
is telling you it's a bad idea you just
use the word courage right which is
cooler is French for heart hmm as is
French for time so courage is a time of
the heart this getting into your heart
that's what the that's what the
opposition and that's what the SWAT down
is all about it's forcing you if you're
gonna come up with courage it's forcing
you to get into your heart and then it's
in your heart which is nonlinear
non-logical non language oriented just
don't own don't all funked all that's
when you can really become that person
that you're going to be so all of these
things like you know you dam a river and
it rises to the occasion and fall flows
over the top that's the nature of
evolution because evolution touches us
in the same way creates a crisis the
crisis needs and a solution solutions
are tried and tried and tried and
finally something works and we move
forward in evolution just like what's
happening in the world at large in the
macrocosm yeah well I truly believe that
that every person has a unique blueprint
and yeah yeah it's our job to bring
expression to that and that doesn't mean
I've said this many times before it
doesn't mean you're gonna be a
world-record-holding athletes you're not
gonna necessarily play in the NBA or be
a rock star or you know be a youtube or
whatever it is play the violin
exactly but there is something unique to
you something that gets you excited when
you wake up in the morning
generally it's something that you
experienced as a young child that
suddenly that got kind of erased along
the way mm who's kissed all torrents
pharmd along the way yeah conformed to
normal and I find it imperative that
people find a means to bring voice to
that spark to that impulse and it
doesn't mean that you quit your job
overnight and reorganize your life on a
dime but I don't believe that you can be
fully expressed and actualized if you're
repressing any of those instincts to
engage in something that brings you joy
there was a time in my life that I
wanted to change something really
important it was it was vital that I
make this change and I gave myself a
five-year plan I can I succeeded and
completed in three years so I what was
that
mom it was just that I was going to come
out of this work that I was doing and
which was I was doing to supplement the
teaching I was doing to supplement the
music right and I was going to just go
all in teaching and I gave myself a
five-year plan and in three years all I
was doing was just teaching and playing
music and it's I think essential that
when you said just a moment ago it's not
that you're gonna turn on a dime I think
it's essential that we do we explain you
from your examples me from mine what
that means what does that mean to set a
goal so that it's not so close that you
don't have enough runway and then will
you know suffer the disappointments and
the setbacks and it's also not so dream
time that there's no pragmatics there's
no things that you're measuring along
the way so how do we do that
well how did you do it
very Nestle well that's an important
component right for the people that are
listening and watching for us to say
you're gonna be a mess and you're gonna
get embarrassed and you're gonna make
mistakes and that's the steps about
opening up that which is unknown to you
in the world of growth and progress and
so you know we get to a place and we go
through school and everything is based
on getting it right but if we're gonna
do what I did and what you say is a less
secured so q8s a circuitous circuitous
way and there go my jangles and my
bangles and you did but as we were as we
were being ignited to make that move we
had been involved in a programming
through school to get it right get it
right get it right so some of the pain
was just the the natural pain of getting
so many things wrong when you decided to
go out be yourself do your own thing
because like you said earlier you know
every single one of us is completely
unique unique fingerprints unique
eyeprint unique voiceprint unique DNA
print and so if we're really going to be
our self and not conform then we're
gonna be unique and we have to go there
gradually so that we don't get so much
pushback on our uniqueness that we get
squashed yeah I think that's wise
counsel just to kind of play this out in
an example so let's say violin is your
thing you played violin and I did did
you the worst sound except as you're
starting you sound worse than any other
instrument in the world as a kid you
loved it but then along the way it's
like no time to you know get on the path
everyone else it falls by the wayside
you find yourself 20 years later with
this impulse to reconnect with that
you're the violet or the Attic you're
repressing it though because you don't
have time and you got to pay the bills
and all of that but you finally summon
the gumption the courage to pull it out
of the closet and start playing it again
I think it's if you find passion in that
and you have the audaciousness to then
set a goal
maybe that goal is to be a professional
by a violin player I mean that's you
know that's a very ambitious goal I
think it's just as important to and let
me back up like set that goal and then
set stepping-stone goals along the way
towards achieving that goal
I think it's just as important to sort
of place that goal in your unconscious
awareness and just fall in love with the
impulse that brought it up in the first
place which is that you like playing
violin you just doesn't matter whether
you become a professional filin player
or not you are committed to making sure
that you make time to engage in that on
a daily basis and and if you're coming
from the heart the core I believe that
the universe will show up with a path or
opportunities that will direct you if
you're adequately anchored in yourself
enough to be aware of those as they
arise beautiful you just talked about
both sides of the brain because you said
in addition to setting the ultimate
outcome and the steps along the way
which would all be using the left
rational side of the brain you've got to
put it in the unconscious that you have
this dream you've got to put it in the
dream time which is the right creative
side of the brain or at least that is
the side of the brain that has a greater
access to that unconscious and and that
is how people anybody that has ever
really succeeded at something really
dramatic whether it's whether their
success was just enjoying the heck out
of something
or being noted professionally they've
had to put it in both sides because I
believe that that's where a lot of
people that are more inclined towards
let's say spirituality than they are
towards formality you know the the
conditions of form I think that's where
they might also lose track because so
much is put into that into that right
creative side that access to the
unconscious that the stepping stones
along the way are neglected so I would
say if your goal is to come out of
conformity to whatever degree you want
to come out of it that you need to use
both of exactly what you were just
describing you need to have some
stepping stones and an ultimate goal and
you need to activate your dream time
brain yes so that you you can work with
both the measurements and the visions
most people are better at one than the
other I agree you need both but it's why
you know musicians need managers and
it's why accountants need some kind of
muse to counterbalance one side Dizzy
Gillespie I think it was dizzy was asked
if he could read sheet music and he said
yeah but not well enough to spoil my
style yeah so I think you know the most
successful have a have a healthy
combination of those two things but I
really believe that if it is what you're
truly meant to be pursuing or engaged in
that it shouldn't matter because it is
the process and the journey it is the
experience of the doing that is far more
important than whatever destination
you're you're driving towards so in
other words we put the GPS system in the
unconscious and just let it play out in
the background
if we completely get off course it will
beep or set off a siren I guess if
you're paying attention those bumpers
you know will become apparent and then
going in your inspiration right in
spirit-inspired you'll be just naturally
intuitively guided but what about the
person who is listening to this or
watching this and they're so stuck in
their current situation and so
disconnected that they don't know the
first step like I don't know like all I
know is it is that I'm settling in my
life I'm in a job that's okay it's not
great it's not what I thought I was
gonna do but you know I can I can do it
and it's fine and they're just in this
semi numbed out state they know that
perhaps their life could be a lot better
they know that they're not maximizing
their potential but what they don't know
is what that thing is that's going to
get them excited how do you begin to
unravel that knot for somebody I love
that it's like the Chinese finger trap
the harder you pull the harder you're
stuck the person that is so in that
malaise that they don't even know the
first step needs to go before the first
step and then before that and the
movement inside of them really can only
happen in breathing so very practically
I would have them sit down and set aside
five minutes every single day start with
five minutes after a month increase it
to ten after a month increase it to
fifteen and in that five minutes just
sit be aware that you are breathing and
be breathing diaphragmatic ly like the
proper way that we breathe when we're
exerting in any kind of effort great
effort that the belly goes out as you
inhale and the belly comes in and the
shoulders remain relaxed and ultimately
what's happening is that you're
massaging the diaphragm you're getting a
lot of engorgement in the heart center
in the heart cavity and all of a sudden
you're oxygenating your blood and brain
more and you're doing nothing except
breathing and things will come to you so
that like that finger trap the Chinese
finger trap you're not pulling hard but
you're sliding out you're sliding out of
being stuck that's how I have found
people to be the most successful but it
means setting aside five minutes mm-hmm
everybody's got five minutes
everybody's got five yeah and I think
when you when you do that over time you
do start to develop a deeper heart
connection and your awareness starts to
blossom and I think it's important when
those impulses start to arise like you
have a flash of inspiration something
out of the blue to write it down or take
it seriously
because the impulse the kind of built-in
reaction to that is to dismiss it
because it's anathema to whatever life
like we we have this you know habit that
we've developed over many many years of
sloughing off those kinds of things when
they arise because they don't comport
with the trajectory that you're on mmm
and people should remember the pushback
because even when you're celebrating
your uniqueness and you have found a
degree of success there will be moments
along the way in which you're going to
hit a rut you're gonna get pushed back
you're going to get opposition and
nobody likes it but you've got to
remember that that early stage of push
back is getting you accustomed to that
and once you're accustomed to it you
figure out a way of overcoming it in
other words when things keep blocking
you they're a good teacher because
they're giving you a consistent
opportunity to learn the lesson of how
to get through the blockages I think
it's also important to understand that
the reason people don't like it has
nothing to do with you correct right
it's it's basically one of two things
and I'm interested in your thoughts on
this it's either because they're
projecting this idea that they have of
you on to you and the minute you don't
conform to that image it's threatening
to them it doesn't fit their mold of who
this person is that they think you are
and are supposed to be which has nothing
to do with you and everything to do with
them and secondly it can be threatening
especially the further down the line you
are because if you start to blossom and
flourish in a new and different way that
they were originally not very excited
about that is proof positive that
somebody can change their life and do
something different and that's
threatening to somebody who is perhaps
not as self expressed as you are in that
moment of time and it's reminding them
that they too could make some changes
and that's very frightening uh-huh and
what we have to remember is that that
which we are trying to hide by
conforming by striving to be normal is
ultimately only hidden from our self or
not I went to my 20th high school
reunion many years ago and I looked
about Hilaire and I looked at just like
I look maha my beard was darker but I
look just like I look now and people
would come up to me and say I knew you'd
end up like this because the reality is
is that that which you're trying to hide
people know about it and so if you would
feel a little more comfortable take a
little more
risk and step into yourself people would
to a degree applaud it to a degree feel
threatened by it and to another degree
feel like it's too much mm-hmm what is
it they say what is the journey from
being not enough to being too much I
don't know what do they say well the
bottom line is is that when you're not
being you you feel like you're not
enough so that's a stimulant right and
ultimately when you're really being you
people say you're full of yourself
you're too much and so you have to be
able to as you were saying just a moment
ago the idea of it's not about you when
people are opposing you it's not about
you it's about what they're seeing
imagine in today's world the bigotry
that's coming up all of this is a
genetic bigotry this is a DNA seeing
something that is different than I what
what I am this is why this whole race
thing and there is no such thing as race
there's paint jobs there's no such thing
we're we're the human race we're not
anything with it there were no race
within the human race and the idea that
our DNA
is noticing a difference so what are you
controlled by are you controlled by your
physical body or are you controlled by
your soul spirit and the more that
you're controlled by your soul spirit
the less you will see the differences as
being meaningful and so you will be very
encouraging to those who want to become
their uniqueness because them being
their uniqueness is just like you but on
the reverse side those that are feeling
trapped in their physical environments
are also feeling trapped in their own
DNA well my experience is that people
who are fully expressed and self
actualized or more so than most people
they are people who are very generous of
heart because they feel good in their
own bodies they know that they're living
their lives in a manner that's
consistent with their deepest values and
so other people don't pose a threat to
that it's only when there's dissonance
in
you're living between your lifestyle and
your values or this person you wish you
could be or think that you should be but
you're not that other people being fully
expressed pose a threat yeah it creates
this zero-sum game perspective you don't
like seeing people fully Express because
you know that you're not mm-hmm when you
were talking I was thinking that
zero-sum the universe is not a zero-sum
environment and that zero-sum of that
which gains must equal that which loses
is an interesting attitude that is very
much an industrial attitude imagine a
farmer who thinks that every amount of
gain through the growth of his crop
means that he's going to lose something
so in the agrarian times when we were
more natural thinking of plant-based
foods right a plant-based condition is
not a zero-sum game an animal-based diet
is a zero-sum game a flesh based diet is
a zero-sum game and so if we were to
think of ourselves in breaking out of
conformity because conformity is a
zero-sum game
conformity means that everything is
equal and we're just sitting inside of
that equality but if we break out we
have to also break away from that
zero-sum ideology we have to become that
which is more prosperous Pro spirit
prosperous we have to become that which
is abundant you in your running and in
your swimming and in your bicycling if
it was a zero-sum game you'd collapse
after a certain number of miles but the
fact that you have this incredible in
energy to push you through those painful
moments is the same thing that we have
to be expressing when in our life
we're striving to become not normal not
conformed but our unique self because we
hit those walls like we hit I remember
hitting a wall once back when I was
running a lot hmm you hit a lot yeah
did you our daughter and our son super
athlete yeah now that I knew yeah the
bottom line is that you hit them a lot
and they are they are the consolidation
of all of your Agony's in that moment I
think it's important to point out that
it's it's a hard journey
you know I've called it the Warriors
path like it's not easy
none calamity and and I think you know
kind of thinking about you being at your
at your high school reunion and people
saying yeah of course like I always knew
you know people look at me and they're
like yeah I always knew you'd do
something a little bit off you know
kilter yeah whenever well I was like
where were you you know back when I was
you know they weren't nobody was saying
that then when you were in your agony
yeah so it requires that level of deep
seeking whether it begins with the
breath like you said meditation yoga
physical exercise journaling I mean I
stats for me this started when back in
like 1998 when I started doing breath
exercises and I started journaling and
if I was to go back and read my journals
from 1998 when I was doing morning pages
in the artists way from 1998 through
2005 you know like most of them are
about how I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know what I want to do or be like
time and again and again and again which
is a showing up for that this doesn't
happen overnight people look at it now
and they're like look at you guru Singh
you get to teach and you do all these
things you can go to Abu Dhabi and
you're fully expressed and you can you
can just rock these crazy outfits and
everybody loves it and it's like how do
you how does this happen you know or how
rich how do you go from you know being
this person who was unhappy to doing
something that's fulfilling and getting
to connect with people all over the
world through the podcast and the books
and things like that you know I don't
have a pat 5-step answer
that it took me essentially 20 years to
like figure this out but you have to
plant those seeds you have to invest in
yourself you have to fertilize that soil
and just perpetually keep showing up for
it even if even if you're seeing no
results going between inspiration and
desperation that's what I would say to
people desperation being the pain of
that push and pull that goes on the
agony and the inspiration that thing
which wakes you up and get you excited
about moving forward with your day I can
remember moments of desperation I can
remember moments of inspiration and I
know that walking in between the two and
never getting that's the middle path the
Buddha talked about never getting
distracted or overly attracted to either
one see I look at you and I think well
this guy just knew who he was from the
minute yeah right
from the first minute right like it or
not yeah let's scatter that because if
we go forward with that myth and I am
worthless as far as my ability to reach
and teach because if people think well
good for him because he was born that
way yeah I was born you know in a in a
very special family but I'll tell you my
Agony's came from inside and outside
just like everybody else's and so yeah
shatter the myths of you know the hero
always sat on top of the pedestal
because it's just not true it's not true
with any of the great prophets and
messiahs of the world the Buddha the cry
Jesus Muhammad Zoe Esther Moses Abraham
all of them I mean the patent stories
the marketing stories are that you know
the one and only and always was and from
the moment of birth you know nonsense
nonsense we all have to go through the
pain
pain is a great teacher whoa and so his
inspiration but if we don't if we're not
willing to go through the pain
then we'll always become less than and
less than and less than until we die and
then all we feel in the moment of death
is just the incredible agony up
I could have mmm yeah it's not about
avoiding the pain it's about trying to
figure out what the message and the
opportunity is within the pain mmm
beautiful do you do you ever look back
on your career I'm sure people have said
to you like why didn't you just become a
rock star like you had a moment where
you were kicking it with Janis Joplin
and Jimi Hendrix and in the graph is
that their deal and the dead and you
were all positioned to go on this
certain you know skyward trajectory
towards musical Fame yeah and all money
runs away from head right but you could
have burned in you know infamy forever
yeah you have you know I was actually
thinking about that because as I was
driving out here today I'm driving
through a neighborhood that was very
much a part of that moment in my life
right early 20s and not the neighborhood
of a small neighborhood I mean just the
you know the valley and what-have-you
and the hills and but and I'm and I'm
thinking back in time and I'm thinking
wow how blessed to have had the
hardships the change of directions the
challenges and all of those things that
took me away from the trajectory of just
being another great you know musician
hmm so when you were in that situation
and had to make that decision how did
you know that you were making the right
choice I wasn't making a choice yeah
it's interesting you say when I was
making that decision the decision that I
was making was to become safe because if
you read my book buried treasures you
find that at a certain point my
trajectory even within
the you know the the conformity of a
record deal and corporate you know
musical promotion etc there was a lot of
pressure on me to get even more silenced
could it even more conformed and because
it just wouldn't work inside of me
because I couldn't play and write in
that genre you know boy meets girl and
everything's cool and you know like it
just didn't work for me right I left
that to other artists that the pressure
coming down on me
did exactly what had happened to you
when you were trying to be a lawyer the
pressure coming down on you was from the
inside just like a volcano erupting from
inside and I I couldn't take it anymore
so I just I I basically ran away from
the structure and pursued my music in a
way that was you know less confining
right and here you are and Here I am
today and here you are today
alright well let's uh let's wrap this
guru corner session up with a song you
brought your guitar I did I thought I
would play a version of this song that I
recorded with a group
[Music]
I
exactly why
[Music]
why
who
[Music]
our minds rejoice rejoice
let your own music start
let your light shine
[Music]
you're so
let your good times roll
[Music]
do I
yeah always a pleasure my friend love
you and love you too so if you're
digging on guru Singh you can find him
on the Internet at guru Singh yogi
should read his book buried treasures
and soon to be back on the podcast and
if you're in Los Angeles
go to yoga West and experience his
Kundalini Yoga class in person which is
a combination of all that rich and I
have been talking about right all right
so I have a feeling I'm gonna see you
again soon but until then peace plants
namaste
[Music]
you